and now welcome back tim anderson back
in the lineup today after the hamstring
injury put him on the injured list for
10 days
and the good news for the sox is that
tim anderson when he is in the lineup he
creates big time differences ah what
will the white sox do
after yesterday's performance from
carlos rhoda the weather today 48
degrees but the forecast is 42 because
today
is the anniversary of the 1947 day when
jackie robinson broke the color barrier
in major league baseball everyone's
wearing 42 today we know how important
this day is to tim anderson and he is
back in the lineup last time out you
could hardly be any better except if
you're carlos rodon you gave up five
hits no runs bear in mind the last five
years they've had a grand total of one
nine inning shutout in this ballpark
we've seen two in this home stand
oh two
got him strike three that
is a strong start
for lance lynn rosario didn't like it
it's a perfect pitcher's pitch and
rosario might not like it
tim anderson's return a first pitch hit
into left field and thus
he breaks the heart of aaron savali
who was trying to match carlos for don
from last night adam eaton will stand in
at 262 with three home runs
it gets through
almost picked off tim anderson who's
going to go all the way to third
and the throws a little late and down to
second
eaton is out
oh and he pushes the shortstop of ed
rosario and now cesar hernandez gets in
there
and here come the benches oh my goodness
in the first inning adam eaton and
andres jimenez
going at it in the middle of the field
the bullpens have spilled out and this
is going to be big trouble
both of the teams are out behind second
base after last night's no-hitter from
carlos rodon eaton can't believe it he
was punched out at second base if you
come off the bag you're obviously
eligible to be tagged and out however
a defender cannot push the base runner
off the bag and that's exactly what
jimenez did now he does beat the play at
second base no doubt about it and then
watch what jimenez does it was like a
hook and hold in basketball juan came up
big last night early in the first inning
drove in the first run set the table for
mercedes three-run homer payoff from
savali
johan pumps it to center field this is
down sox lead tim anderson returns tim
anderson scores a run that's usually the
case if he gets on to lead off the
inning it turns into a run well that's
the back breaker right there you got
somali that's one pitch away from
getting out what look was going to be a
disastrous ending with back to back base
hits and just like that montana spoils
everything with the two out base hit
lanceland really enjoying featuring that
fastball so far throwing it with a lot
of confidence in attack mode to say the
least
one to bowers
and he hits it to left field that'll be
the first base runner for cleveland
in the ball game it's a hit for bowers
and if you are joining white sox
baseball only for no hitter history
you're allowed to leave but please don't
bowers was hitting 0.59 coming into that
at bat ahmed rosario with two outs so
lead double by bowers but now with two
gone he's still at second base
2-2 he struck him out swinging
after the lead-off double three
strikeouts he's got six early on big
frannie reyes
the dh
round out victim his first time up two
strikes on reyes the pitch swinging a
miss
to end the inning he's got seven
strikeouts through four it is still
one nothing white sox
jake bowers and the tribe's first hit
today his second hit of the year first
extra base hit took a pitch and doubled
it the other way down the left field
line 2-2
and he struck him out swinging
eight
for lynn
yeah he's trying to match that nine
strikeouts he had last time in the
shutout against kansas city the indians
and the white sox more dominant pitching
and we have said that all weekend long
from two of the finest pitching staffs
in all of baseball and today no
exception delivers and it's swung on
this is socked high in the air to deep
right center long run for eden and
robert ball hits the track jumps into
the seats ground rule double to right
center as andre siemens has his second
double of the year and the indians have
their third hit in the game the indians
had a leadoff double from jake bowers in
the third and then lynn struck out the
next three ramirez is hitless in his
last 19 advance now the payoff
swing and a high drive this has hit a
ton deep right eaton track wall gone
a two-run home run to right and jose
ramirez with two down in the sixth has
put the indians on top
two to one
well you gotta credit lynn
he just stuck with a fastball kept
challenging ramirez
and ramirez that time
a little more under control with his
swing and launches a two out two run
homer to right and the indians now lead
it by a score of two to one here in the
sixth inning andre simenas is the banner
he has struck out doubled and scored
last stunning on the jose ramirez home
run
puts it in play
and the throw to first they get the out
the run scores it's three to one
cleveland give jimenez and rbi his third
of the year put it in play
and he does he's on the line
going on contact he might have had a
chance the indians up three to one they
now have a runner at second with nobody
out in the pits
and it's swung on grounded sharply off
the glove of abreu at first kicks into
foul ground the throw to the pitcher
covering gets away coming home and
scoring is hernandez and ramirez goes to
second
a smash on the ground
toward the line at first that a bray you
get a glove on and then kind of kicked
it into foul ground from reyes
a run in first and second
3-2 is hammered in the air to deep left
vaughn at the wall and he makes a
leaping grab
i don't think it would have gotten out
but it absolutely would have been extra
bases off the top of the fence
nice catch by andrew vaughan
so that error makes the run unearned but
it also gives chicago a chance with one
swing of the bat to tie this game and
adam eaton
claus says pitch
swung on lifted high in the air deep
left center gamel back in front of the
track makes the catch ball game
so class a gets the save and the indians
get out of chicago with a split in the
four-game series